I mean don't want to start off by asking
you about one of your tweets oh so a
random staff by twin city was a retweets
I messaged my one of your co-stars from
Alcatraz sam neill right and in it he
said that acting is a really funny job
yes every time you do it it feels like
starting again from the very beginning
yeah and I wondered what your experience
was with that and what it had been like
with 28k in particular you know what he
which is why we tweeted it because it's
ranked so true to me that every time you
start a new project you're like oh my
god you say yes and then you're like
they're gonna find me out it's like I
can't do this it's like they've got the
wrong person right I don't know why that
is but it just it is like starting all
over again and you just you know he
described it best of all so I don't want
to embellish too much but it but yeah it
does feel like that and I'm not quite
sure why how about with Frenette k did
that feel like that look like you know
yeah because you're creating a brand new
character and it's you know and also
because of the amount of work that it
consisted of because I'm literally in
nearly almost all of it you know just to
pace it correctly and making sure that
you're creating a very rounded character
and you know that has all these facets
to them you know they're strong they're
vulnerable and you know they can be
scared they can be you know obnoxious
whatever it's like you know making sure
it's a fully rounded piece that you're
not playing the same thing and it's you
know it's a challenge and I hope we
achieved that it's a little bit about
your character diva and what trying to
detail well I loved about diva was the
just such a strong female lead which I
feel like you don't really see very much
of and especially in a gangster movie
you know normally you'd see a guy in
this role and and I just loved the
challenge of playing someone like that
and you know she's a she's obviously got
her own demons to fight with you know
you sort of pick up you know where she's
working in Paris as a buyer and then you
see her come back to the East End and
and she knows the people that she meets
and when she comes back and he's
mentioned there that she
is in Paris at the very start yeah he's
working those and she's a fashion
executive she comes back to London which
is where most of the film takes right so
she's got that kind of difficulty we're
kind of settling back in I guess but
seeing people she knows yeah kind of
being in the same place again where
she's like them for a while although I
almost don't think she has difficulty
settling back in I think her clothes
sort of make it look like she has
difficulty settling back here you know I
think you know it's like it's a I said
this before it was like you can take the
girl out of the East End but you can't
say that you send out the girl it's like
she really just gets on with it and she
goes to the places that she knows that
will help her and you know in the
situation with her brother and you know
she knows that world only too well which
is why she left and I think she's she's
fine with coming back to it but she
doesn't want to be there for long
because she knows what it's about I mean
how did you find yourself because
obviously you've lived and worked in LA
for a while yeah you coming back to
London to write this um I you know I
just it didn't it was a different part
of London for me to experience it like
which is what I love about London so
much is that you couldn't go anywhere in
London and it's so different in so many
different but even if you just turn a
corner you know it's like suddenly a
different place but you know I lived in
South London for a long time completely
different two doors London and now here
I am back in the East End I mean I one
of my first Jobs was in the East End and
now going back to the East End it's
changed so much also because of the
Olympics it was just nice to experience
that different side and and I lived
somewhere else as well which was another
experience of London right I loved it
and as that backdrop to the Olympics in
the film as well is it there yes what's
your kind of feeling about London 2012 I
you know I'm a huge supporter of it I
just think you know anything that can
make a nation feel a little bit better
about themselves especially you know
globally you know how things are going
right now I just think it's great and I
love sports so I love watching them I
love seeing the athletes compete and and
it truly is about how good they are as
opposed to who they know that's why I
love it so much it's like they really
win by their own merit so I am excited I
I ran with the Olympic torch it was last
year two years ago something like that
it was amazing absolutely amazing the
buzz around the town and even driving
around now the buzz is just amazing what
did it feel like when you were asked to
do that I was I was like really hot
myself
Wow but to you know run across the
millenium bridge towards st. Paul's
Cathedral with like all these people out
like cheering you on
with this it was a met it was just
amazing I was very honored very very
honored and of course this is a British
film as well as it talk about
Britishness and being yeah how important
is it for you to star in a British film
it's so hard to make films I feel like
in England as it is right now so it's
very important and it's sort of you know
it's Who I am and it's I want to be able
to do that I want to be able to do that
whenever I can and as often as possible
and I'm just always glad when I get the
opportunity to do it and what's next for
you I'm just plugging away
I just finished Alcatraz actually not so
long ago it wasn't that long ago tour
and I actually just did a comedy series
in the u.s. like to play do Lay's new
girlfriend so I've been having a lot of
fun doing that it's nice to go on set
and just laugh a lot they were like
crying in a lot of other stuff so it was
good just to that was the primary focus
they were sad to see much Alcatraz
oversee computer nerds but were would
you've liked to seen it go if it had
continued I just you know I think like
everybody like you know our audience and
the actors are like we just wanted some
sort of closure and it would have been
nice to have had another 13 episodes to
explain a little bit about you know
where it was going because it was just
becoming interesting and I'm sad it got
the plug pulled on it yeah it was
interesting recently you can go back to
a tweet so you tweeted that you know
you're asking people what would you like
what if you brought er by I was working
somebody from NBC might see it but I
think everybody thought I knew something
that they didn't you know what I would
do that so in a heartbeat again and with
those people I just absolutely loved it
and I'd go back and do Neela in a shot
you like to see happen to her
it was you making the decisions I don't
know I'm not as clever as those writers
and she's why I want to go back into it
because those writers were amazing
you